القوات عند القوات خصني ندوز عليهم باش
نعمل العمليه عليهم هذا خص يكون بعمل
انساني طبيب خاصه يكون عنده واحد النباله
بانه يدير الفعل الخير وما يكونش فيه
الماده حنا كنعرفو
ديك اولا الولوج الى التطبيق في العام
الماضي انفقت جمعيه يلا نتعاونوا الخيريه
اكثر من خمسه ملايين درهم مغربي لتغطيه
عمليات جراحيه لنحو 700 مريض ممن لا
يشملهم التامين الصحي انقاذ الارواح
وانقاذ الناس واللي تجيبهم من ابعد
الاماكن الممكنه وحتى في المدن كنلقوا
حالات اللي هي في مدينه ومن اصعب الحالات
اللي تقدر تنزل عليك
بالغلاء ديال العمليه اللي احنايا ممكن
تجينا اولا التغطيه صحيه اللي ما كايناش
كبير استقبلت جمعيات غير حكوميه تشتغل في
المغرب في مساعده المرضى الفقراء بمبادره
العاهل المغربي الملك محمد السادس بتوفير
التغطيه الصحيه الشامله للفئات الاجتماعيه
الفقيره عادل الزبير العربيه من مدينه
طنجه في شمال المغرب